well welcome back everyone to the data science
hangout if you're joining for the first time
it's great to meet you i'm rachel i'm the host
as i mentioned last week it's really nice to be
able to share some space with everyone right now
so we do want to reiterate and share again some
of the avenues to help those that are affected by
the war in ukraine that have been shared by viola
and sup but also ask others to share in the chat
as well thank you everyone if this is your first
hangout this is an open space for the whole data
science community to connect and chat about data
science leadership questions you're facing and
what's going on in the world of data science
so we want to create spaces where everybody
can participate and we can hear from everyone
there's three ways to ask questions probably more
you can jump in live and raise your hand on zoom
you can put questions in the zoom chat and feel
free to put a star next to it if you want me to
read it out loud if it's maybe loud where you
are or something like that but we also have a
slido link where you can ask questions anonymously
and our team will share that in the chat in just
a second here just like to reiterate that we
love to hear from everyone no matter your level
of experience or area of work too but with all
of that i'm so happy to be joined by my co-host
for today kirsty angel christie is a senior data
scientist interview coach and data science mentor
at what says on the website grubhub and zach
already stole it from me but congratulations
are in order for your new role now at stitchfix
so chrissy i'd love to have you introduce yourself
and maybe share a little bit about your
role sure thanks for that rachel uh so
yes i'll be joining um i'll be joining stitchfix
uh on their ab experimentation platform team
um i probably shouldn't preface that with a b
because i'm assuming it does a little bit more
than just a b testing but uh i don't quite know
yet so we'll see tbd but as you might imagine my
background is specialized in experimentation uh
data science and inference causal inference um
i started in experimentation back in 2016 right
after i graduated with my master's in statistics
um i started at groupon and at the
time web-based experimentation um
was not a it's not what it was today i'll tell you
that i remember right before i interviewed for my
first job i would i googled uh you know optimize
experimentation web experimentation and found very
little information and now it's everywhere so um
i feel like i kind of lucked into a little niche
that said um on the in my free time um there
are several several other things that i do to
contribute to the data science community one of
those things is that i am a data science mentor
through a boot camp called thinkful um this boot
camp i mentor data scientists and data analysts
we um the thing that's unique about this
particular program is that we pair students
with mentors in addition to their full-time
or part-time curriculum that they choose so
they really get to work with somebody in industry
understand how data science is actually applied
uh and how that's different than a classroom
environment and then the other thing that i've
been a little bit more focused on recently
is interview coaching for that same student
population so i primarily work with data analysts
and data science graduates from boot camp programs
and i conduct mock interviews with them because
a lot of these these students and candidates
are fresh out of of this boot camp they might be
career pivoters they could be phd students who
are looking to bridge some skills gaps they
might also be um you know just right out of
undergrad or maybe they didn't go to uh college
at all i actually had a student recently who
uh was in the military and then he came out and
did did um a boot camp and so there are just a
lot of different needs but i would say there's
also a lot of anxiety around the mystery of
what comprises a technical interview and so
um i think one of my favorite parts is just
getting people to a place where they're feeling
confident in their interviewing ability and
that is a lot of um it's a lot of just recognizing
that anxiety that's there um so yeah in a nutshell
so thanks kirsty while we're waiting for
questions to come in from everyone i'd love
to learn a little bit more about that and maybe
some of the tips that you share with people when
you're coaching them for interviews or
how you help them get over that anxiety
excuse me um absolutely so um you know i think
one of the first things that i always like to
do is just kind of put out my feelers um and
the way that i do that is i just i come right
out and say you know if you're anything like me
i am a nervous interviewer you know like i just
i just put it right out on the table and make it
okay to fess up and say me too uh that way we can
just kind of talk about the elephant in the room
and and bring the level down a little bit um
i also think that uh my interview style is it
it matches the interview style that i like to to
be interviewed with which is conversational um
it's collaborative and um you know i'm not gonna
ask questions like you know guess what number i'm
thinking uh you know i do want to understand
your thought process but if you get stuck um
i don't want to watch this i'm not going to leave
you to struggle i'm going to nudge you forward
and and and really it doesn't take a lot but
um i think realizing that that's all it is
for people uh is really really helpful because
i think they get caught up in this data science
um universe where it's like
well they could ask me anything
they could but they're probably going to
focus on the job description in your resume
so let's narrow the focus and just
bring bring it down a little bit
do people do that then when they get to
their interview i have seen i have seen a lot of
success i really really have i um i offer all of
all of the students that i interview
to connect with me on linkedin
um and keep me posted some do some don't and
that's okay um i love seeing my success stories uh
there was a candidate that um came in to me
a couple months ago and i had to escalate
actually because um i got about 15 minutes into
this mock interview and i realized that this
person was going through some some real trauma
you know he had signaled a couple of times like
you know um i've been i've been working so
hard for so long you know or you know i've
just been struggling for so long and um
it really struck a chord with me because
i i also come from a background where i kind of
had to bootstrap myself up a bit i was a waitress
for 20 years while i put myself through school
um i'm the first person in my family to graduate
from high school um there are some days where
you know on my path it was really really hard
and so when he said that it just connected with
me and i put my interview notes away and i was
like this is a different conversation that we
have to have and so you know we talked about it
and he had this i didn't want to call it imposter
syndrome because i think it's more than that but
it turned out he didn't have a college degree and
he had military experience and he was afraid that
by submitting his application and getting
through an uh applicant tracking system
that he was automatically going to be bounced
away and i said that's fine that might be true
but that's not work what we're gonna do because
that's not how you're going to get a job
you know and we talked about it and i spent
i was supposed to spend an hour on the phone
with this kid i spent an hour and a half talking
him through it and i said i think about halfway
through i'm like you've got yourself a mentor
like i'm just married to this right now but
two weeks later he got a job he just needed a
confidence boost with other people they need to
work on some sql skills you know but being able
to identify those weaknesses early on really sets
them up for success in a good way that's amazing
it brings up a point i know we had talked about
earlier as well like when people don't have
degrees and they're kind of hitting that roadblock
in recruiting and not getting through to the
hiring manager what can we all do to change that
that's interesting because um i did have
another student she is one of the most tenacious
hardest workers committed learners i mean
she would run laps around me i was so
amazed at her tenacity and she was going to i
mean she was going to grace hopper she was going
to all the conferences talking to as many people
as she could talk to doing everything right but
she had a political science degree and um i
think you know she was pie-eyed and talking
to a lot of big tech companies um not really
realizing there were other other avenues but um
she was getting shot down automatically by
a lot of companies because they were saying
that she didn't have a stem degree and i
was really frustrated like part of me was
like i want to find out who those recruiters are
because i thought the same company said that we
don't need degrees anymore and so i feel like
there's this like know a misalignment of well
what are what what what what do we want
from our data scientists and also i think
there's sincerely a knowledge gap um in in some
recruiting teams that we can help with too um and
that's something that i i always try
to do because i end up going to all
the college recruiting events that i can
but um just educating your recruiters on
what different flavors of data science
look like and where they might come from
i absolutely love what's happening in the chat
right now everybody's sharing their majors as well
yeah no social science i love working
with social science teachers i was i
was a stats grad student but um i i i have a
lot of uh sociology phd envy i'll admit that
does anybody have experience with like
working directly with the recruiting team
at your company to kind of say like hey
this is something we might want to look
past here and change the way we're doing it
the the company i work for state space labs is i
think unusual um the founder himself is the first
person in his family to have a college degree you
know bounced through several community colleges
uh you know ended up with a phd in neuroscience
um so you know this is coming from the top down
as you can imagine so the idea of what degree you
have is pretty much irrelevant at the company um
you know whether it's somebody who's being hired
for engineering or data science or anything we
have plenty of people with military backgrounds uh
there are people with high school degrees who work
at the company but i i fully understand that
this is really really unusual and uh you know
i think we're lucky that we have the ceo that we
have and i'm not i'm not sure how you convince
people that you know it's really not just
okay to look past the degree but probably
a really good idea in many cases that you need
diversity of thought and background in order to
especially if your company has a
consumer-facing product and you want
uh the company as a whole to have empathy for end
users i think it's it's really important to have
um a really varied set of of life experience
backgrounds but yeah i'm not i'm not really
sure how you convince people at a more
traditional company that that it's a good idea
that's awesome that your company does
that though jenny i love that yeah
does anyone else have thoughts on on this topic
oh i see matthias you have your hand raised you
want to jump in yeah so we we're a small
start-up in the women's health space and we
kind of look beyond degrees in a lot of ways
a lot of our more senior data science people
have like a biology degree or something like
that right and it's really more about what
they've done in their previous jobs because we
need them to be effective from day one but for
the more junior folks it's kind of difficult right
so what we find is a lot of people with degrees
even if they have a degree they're not very good
right but um when you're more junior and then
on top of that you don't have a degree we just
don't find a lot of talent right we don't find a
lot of people that are very good with that right
it's not like we would be opposed to that but
the degree and the experience gives you a little
bit of a of a certification right it's a little
bit easier to say like okay these are the people
that we should talk to because you know in a
startup there's always more to do than you have
time right so if you if you go really in depth
with like five candidates or ten candidates that's
a lot of drain on the organization right so you're
trying to use these degrees as a little bit of
a of a filter to see who we can talk to quickly
i think that's a good call out in
the startup space in particular
it's a little bit different of a situation
because like you said you need people who
can be effective from from day one hit the
ground running um you know and and and in that
case maybe that's where interns come in uh at
a certain maturity uh once you get there but um
but you know it's definitely one of those things
where you know when you can take on uh a junior
level person i mean we we still have to hire
junior level people because we're all going to get
older it's just not a sustainable model if
we don't um and so i love seeing certain
organizations that do that intentionally think
about like the bandwidth that they have to be
able to train in-house and um companies
launched programs successfully to do that
i see there's a few other hands raised too mike
do you want to jump in yeah i think um i wanted
to ask christy about well first if i can make a
a comment and then ask a question comment is you
you clearly are helping candidates and kind of
training them how to do interviews are you also
training interviewers because you know i think
a lot of interviewers could do with a bit of
skills i agree with that 100 um so when i was at
groupon um my job before my last job gov hub that
was something that i was involved in um towards
the end i was working we had um similar to amazon
we had what we called a bar raiser program and so
um one of the things that i wanted to see happen
um i helped to ensure that that all interview
loops had a diverse representation from the
interviewers that was something that was happening
at a certain level above or above at one point
um or on my team because i would track down the
recruiter and insist on it um but the other thing
uh that we were working on is extending the bar
raiser training program more um more broadly to
like some of those core principles and
tenants to all interviewers because um
interviewing's hard you know i mean i i think i
got thrown into it when i first started doing it
um so i i always interview from the perspective
of kind of an interviewee is you know how how do
i want to be treated and it i think that makes it
hard for me it's one of those things that i still
to this day second guess is um that external
validity it's like was it was it me or was it
was it my question or was it the candidate and
that's not a good place to be in because this is
someone's livelihood that you're that you're
handling and i take that very seriously so
i think that you're right um we all need to learn
to become better interviewers it's um i think that
we make these really complicated frameworks
for interviewing um when really you know if
we just had some uh that's what we're looking
for thoughtful and meaningful conversations
with people about what they've done and what
they know and how they think about things
and we might get further it'd be really nice to
to hear you know what are the kind of conversation
starter questions or you know things that
because as an interviewer you want to get
a feel for whether that person has skill or even
just personality to to deal with the job you're
interviewing for you know what are good starter
questions that you know open them up to kind of
go right you know give me the information but
let's do it in a way that isn't challenging or
you know difficult if you know what i mean i mean
it's supposed to be a little difficult but it's
more as you say it's a kind of you know come on
just just tell me so yeah i mean the first thing
you want to do is you want to try to put them
at ease and develop some trust really quickly
and i wish i could explain to you how to do
that but i was a waitress for 20 years and so
that's that's literally the job is you know hi
table how are you and in three seconds i have to
assess are you hungry grouchy happy like you know
whatever what kind of mood are you in uh you know
and read the room so um i don't i don't know how
it practice uh trial and error making mistakes
yeah i've heard that before in interviews
it's like was i just really drained and
being awkward at starting conversation or was
it just that we weren't weren't connecting
yeah like i think it was maybe it was me but
almost i'm so glad that we have like panels
though because then you can kind of corroborate
the evidence and yeah definitely zach i see you
have your hand raised too do you want to jump
in yeah i was just coming from some that's
as i said i don't go to university in the
uk i believe mike is also from the uk uh
we have something called apprenticeship so
you do four days working one day learning
but the qualification isn't seen in the same way
it's basically i from you basically just get 18
months two years of experience and that's how
you sell yourself rather than the qualification
uh but i i hope coming from some that
as i said i know that i've from the
position i put myself in i don't want to go
to university so i know i have to work harder
what if so i deal with these external stuff
i end competitions and all that stuff um
like build shiny dashboards models but yeah it's
the it's the instant rejection and all this which
i but like sounds like i completely understand
it if they're getting 100 or so applicants
or 200 no one's going to be able to go through
that they have to have a minimum requirement or
yeah as uh as matteo said it's just gonna spend
someone's gonna spend their entire week looking
at one job or two weeks depending on how big it is
so i completely understand it though which is why
i've started looking at smaller companies because
they're more likely to take a chance take a risk
uh have less applicants so what someone's going
to be able to spend looking at it and then
hopefully once they go actually this person's got
an interesting portfolio and get myself into that
so that's what i've been looking i've only been
looking for about two weeks now so it's not like
i'm expecting lots but yeah that's the way that
i'm approaching i'm sure other people have got
uh other ways that they're looking at it so yeah
just someone as someone that's in this for a
different perspective yeah that's great
perspective zach and great that you're doing all
those contests and stuff too like big data bowl
i know we mentioned but um javier i see you had
your hand raised too is do you have uh something
to weigh in on this topic yeah i i i kind of had
a question for christy just to follow up to all
these discussions um because i've experienced
this myself two occasions in my career in my life
um years back i was super unhappy in a job and
you know i was so busy with that job that
finding interviews or getting interviews
applying for jobs felt exhausting and kind of like
a parallel to this i eventually quit that job and
went back to grad school because i was like
okay i'm not getting the types of jobs i want
you know i was reading and learning all about
predictive modeling without even really knowing
what it was i was just very interested in
the way people were presenting on this topic
so i went back to grad school and i experienced
like significant interview fatigue i mean the
first month or two were very exciting you know
you're applying to positions um but after a while
it's it becomes sort of taxing because you're like
okay i have to sound excited about this job like
it no longer becomes fun on a regular basis
to interview and learn about these companies
do you have i don't know what the right answer is
like i've thought about this a lot but do you have
any guidance for people that are you know students
who are kind of feeling this fatigue or just
people unhappy in their current job or or you know
like zach not to put you on the spot but someone
like zach trying to break into the into the space
and applying you know position after position yeah
um i mean i'll tackle the the breaking into the
space piece uh first because i think it's it's
sort of a a slightly different problem um i
i recommend to all of uh my mentees um like
like i mentioned um the fellow who didn't have
a college degree either when i said we're not
gonna go through applicant tracking systems what i
meant was we're going to network and i don't like
the word networking because i think it
automatically puts people up kind of like oh
i don't want to do that but utilize linkedin as
a social media a professional social media site
um you know find people who are generating content
that you find uh compelling and interesting um you
know find your tribe uh once you find your tribe
you know or as you begin finding your tribe engage
they're going to start knowing who you are by your
comments and your feedback and your ideas that
you're contributing and then believe it or not
you're going to start building a reputation for
yourself i mean it's just how human relationships
work uh you don't mean to be doing it but you just
being you that's what happens um that's how i got
my job at stitch fix honestly uh i had followed my
my new boss eric weber on linkedin for some time
um i really align with his style of leadership
when i think about the kind of leader that i
want to be um i want to be like eric um and so
uh we we stayed connected um now i'll i'll
address uh the other question that you had
javier which was you know the interview fatigue
and i can speak to this personally uh because i
was laid off in 2020 due to covid in april um in
fact i had the great fortune of graduating in 2010
during the housing market crash not knowing what
i wanted to do and then yeah anyways um interview
fatigue i interviewed for seven months in 2020 uh
i was planning to uh leave groupon and move on to
my next journey or the next step in my journey um
you know i think i had already been planning that
at the beginning of 2020 and then once i started
applying and covid started the rug just got pulled
out from underneath me because the entire market
changed uh where i thought i had a leg up all of
a sudden got very very competitive and then also
what was happening behind the scenes that made
it incredibly frustrating was that different um
positions were being combined or pulled because
nobody knew where the pandemic was going to go
so talk about frustration i made it all the way
through full rounds with pinterest twice and i
think five times with facebook in a matter of a
couple months so um i get fatigue but i think
personally what i can say is when i finally
felt the most successful um or the most
at ease um was when i just gave into it
you know it's like okay i've done all the hard
work i've prepared all i can prepare um you know
now i just like i just have to show up and
and be the most authentic me that i can be
like i just need to bring her along
for the ride because if she shows up
then i'm good but that's that's where the problem
comes it's like can i is she gonna come today you
know so i think it's just making sure that you're
taking care of yourself enough so that you can be
there i think the other thing is just being really
candid and honest with your recruiting partners
i think people forget that they are your
partners um and so always advocate for
yourself with your recruiters if you wake up
on the day of your interview and like you're
in a panic attack or you know like any number
of things that could happen these days right
don't there's no shame in rescheduling
they want your best self to show up too
they want you to get the job they don't want
to continue continue interviewing forever they
have work that they want to do and they want
you to come along and do the work too so um
just i think for me that was that was what really
unlocked progress for me and and it helped um
it helped bring joy back into it
because it helped me connect with my why
that's great chrissy i can see in the chat
too it's resonating with a lot of people and i
i love i can't read the chat right now but i
love seeing you all talking to each other um i
want to make sure to get to some of the anonymous
questions that were asked too and this is actually
a follow-up to the question now but how do you
stay motivated and optimistic while looking for
a job after like a certain number of rejections
or ghosting from a company first thing i do um
there's there's a couple of things the first
thing i do is um i allow myself a day to grieve
and just feel the way i'm gonna feel um like
i've i i've seen people um who can knock out
interviews back to back you know and even you've
seen people do two final rounds in one day
that's not me um i mean i'm resilient but like
i also need my space to just to work through
my feelings um so if that's you that's okay um i
have a dog who looks like a muppet he helps a lot
uh he gets me out of my head when i just want
to like curl up in bed i still gotta take care
of him um so that helps and he's just goofy
and he makes me laugh um so that's nice um
yeah i i gotta be honest like you really
gotta hunt for positivity these days
but um where you can find it take it and
just kind of relish in it for a little bit
definitely i see matthias you're smiling and
raising your hand too i just i just think that
that's uh such good advice right and i think one
thing um probably also to always keep in mind
uh the people on the other end the people who
hire you are human right so um a there there's
a lot of people who are also and i'm sorry to say
this over and over again there's a lot of people
who are not good at their jobs right so if they
don't hire you there's a lot of people who you
know don't do the diligence they don't put the
work in to find the best candidates so it's not
you right i think that's always important to keep
in mind and then when you do work with good people
and they don't hire you and that's also not a
bad thing because if they know what they're doing
then they know that you're not a good fit that
doesn't say anything about you as a person that
just means hey in this position our assessment is
you might not be as successful as you want to be
so you know take that i know this is like super
hard to take it as that but that is also a
positive trust them right so if you work with good
people trust their judgment if you work with bad
people just brush it off it doesn't matter move
on to the next thing get your feet in the door
once you have the foot in the door do the best
thing you can and build your expertise that's
at least from from the other side from the side
that highest i don't know if that matters or not
and i would add to that you know like
it can be hard to take the ominous like
not a good fit because it's it's vague and it's
like well i thought it was a great fit you know
it's not specific um but if you can imagine
um some realistic scenarios for example like
i mean i've had not a good fit right now um
and and when companies are able to give that
kind of feedback where um well for example
i'll give an example uh i interviewed with
netflix in 2020 is one of the first interviews
that i did because in my mind i'm like not going
to get that job uh and so i figured it would be
a practice interview right um well first of all
it still feels crappy when netflix even if you
don't think you're gonna get the job when netflix
tells you no you're still like well if i can't
get the job i don't want how am i gonna get the
job i do want you know and so it is a constant
mind game and it's a mind game that you have to
outsmart yourself at really um but i think the
other thing is uh what helped me so much in this
this interview round where um that i just went
through that same recruiter reached back out to me
now a year and a half later um they remember you
and apparently what i didn't know at the time was
and this is so funny to me apparently i nailed the
statistics round which i think was the one that i
thought i did the the least uh well in
and it just wasn't as efficient in sequel
and it's like well i mean yeah okay i mean i can
i can practice sql drills more but that was it
so um that felt great to know that like i was
that close and getting that feedback helps
because you're like okay i'm not far off i am
on the right path people do like you know what
i have to contribute but they just don't need
me right now or they need something slightly
different yeah and if you work with a good company
they are always happy to give you that feedback
right if you ask right no one likes to have
that conversation unprompted but if you if
you ask them like hey what was it um they
will always have constructive feedback there
yeah christy robert and i were talking
a little bit earlier on slack about um
like red flags to look out for when you're
interviewing with a company um and i think
right now like we see a lot of recruiter emails
from people maybe promises huge salaries or
like how do you decide which opportunity to take
or to interview for out of some of the others
yeah um okay hang on let me just jot this
down because i i wanna those are i think
two really good um questions i wanna address
separately so red flags and then there was
um i'm sorry what was the second question
um how did you decide which opportunity
to go after or to take yeah okay so um first let's
start with red flags um for me it depends on like
what your values are right uh for me personally
things that i value in a position um are uh you
know immediately having that feeling where it can
be my authentic self that like i feel that natural
ease of communication um maybe sense of humor some
laughter um i want to know that like we can work
together and i i like to work in a fun environment
i like to bring a sense of humor um and so just
making sure that like we're on the same page
there because uh like this is what you get
like what you see is what you get with me and i'm
very upset about that so um so i i'm particular
um i i value uh people with diverse backgrounds
um you know so a diverse team i i value um
i value learning i value building for the long
term um i value innovation i value you know
so i think about my values and i'm trying
to find a team that fits with that um
and i i like i knew a lot about eric going in
so that one was a no-brainer for me um in fact
like i approached him because i i wanted to work
with him before um so i try to shop for managers
if i'm honest if i can i will always shop
for a manager um and if i feel like i'm not
like connecting a culture like on the same page in
terms of culture that's where all my questions are
gonna go if i don't get a sense of that from
them immediately i'm going to ask about it
and my favorite questions is just can you
describe your team culture um unsurprisingly
the same person who introduced
themselves as a princeton ph.d
struggled to define their team culture
so you know to me that was a red flag
i'm trying to think of other like
i look for managers who really
care about growing their team members um i think
some managers forget that's part of their job
um and that's okay you know because managers
also are new managers sometimes um you know
and maybe you're not supported the way that they
need to be supported but um those are those are
the things that i look for and if i'm not getting
a vibe that that's there i'm i'm gonna keep moving
what factors so those are some of
the factors that drove my decision
early on my job search i was really torn
because i was unsatisfied where i was um
for no reason other than just like personally
i think logistics is kind of boring it's like a
bunch of time stamps and uh it doesn't i want
to see um like more direct impact on people
um and to me uh as someone who's
worked on experimentation platforms
uh the people i impact are are my colleagues
my stakeholders so i have a special place in
my heart for internal tooling um and i think i i
for a long time i grappled with that point because
i felt like i wasn't a whole data
scientist because i had never
done more algorithmic data science or machine
learning i've never put a model into production um
but my last project that my last role was putting
together an experimentation training program
and i got to write and i got to teach and i got
to just like brain dump all of the things that i
know about experimentation and i think
simultaneously i've been really struggling
with trying to understand what confidence
is like at the core what is confidence
and when i was observing myself just fluidly
explaining what experimentation is and how to
do it to non-technical people in a very like
plain and simple way i was like wait a minute
this is confidence i mean i'm being confident
right now and so um i just realized like
this is this is what i know how to do well
and i'm at the point in my life you know
i'm not i don't have enough time to be an expert
in everything um and so maybe i just be an expert
in testing and i can collect more hobbies
and do fun stuff on the side and enjoy life
i love that finding finding the area
that you're confident in yeah yeah
there's quite a few anonymous questions too
i don't want to to miss let me just jump
over sorry i was like going back and forth
um someone had said i have been working as
a data scientist for three plus years now but
i'm feeling my experience doesn't look valuable
to recruit recruiters just assuming from low
calls do you have any suggestions yeah um so
when i so i kind of approached this problem as
a data scientist and i and i think you know if
you are if you're blind or if you're just kind of
cold applying you know through company websites
um you know then you want to target the top of the
funnel maybe take a take a look at your resume um
maybe maybe see if you can get some resume reviews
from colleagues or peers that you trust um and see
um see what their thoughts are uh if there's
a way that maybe that might be more effective
but again i i still think that if you can get um
referrals or um or you're like i said your resume
into the hands of a hiring manager um there's lots
of hiring managers on linkedin right now that are
blatantly advertising for roles that they're
trying to fill so take advantage of that um
but if it's not a resume problem um you
know and it really is just a matter of
of uh thin content um you know there's a lot
of different ways that you can fill that out
so um let me think here i mean there's
definitely projects that you can do on your own
um there are volunteer organizations
where you can join as part of a team to do
um do projects um i know data science for
social good has an offshoot but i can't remember
the name of it um maybe we can look that up
later and share that out but look for volunteer
opportunities um because then you have the good
fortune of learning from other people as well
um i think going to meetups um particularly
the python and our meetups if you can
another really great way to network and form
community but um you know you just try to build
communities of people um who are willing to to
vouch for you and and pass your resume along
because that's that's the best way um yeah i think
and then like in the situation that you're in
um if you have any say about the projects that
you're working on try to be strategic um see if
there's other projects that you think are valuable
that someone's working on see if you can ask your
manager um if you can be a part of that um in
a small way definitely that's great chrissy and
i i can't speak for everybody here on the call
but i i love the community feel of this too and
i'm sure there's a bunch of people on this call
right now who'd be willing to like take a look
at your resume as well and connect with you but
i do want to say if anybody is in that position
right now feel free to shoot me an email too and
i'll try and help you connect with people as well
people reach out all the time on linkedin
that are on the other side too they're hiring
for roles and they just can't find people and
there just seems to be this mismatch happening
but yeah definitely feel free to reach out to
or if anyone wants to put in the chat if you're
willing to connect with someone too israel i
know you had a somewhat similar question too
so i just wanted to see if you had any other
follow-up to add to uh kind of my question
was uh like for data science roles i see a
lot of requirements for like phd or masters
and i currently for example have a bachelor's
degree and have like some experience a data
analyst um so just trying to see what will be
like the best bridge between them having a masters
um to fulfill um to that like i'm currently
trying to build a github repo very slowly
just because life but other suggestions
we really appreciate it and thank you
uh i i mean it sounds to me like you are
already you know your head's in the right
place and you're thinking of the right things
um i mean i'll be the i'll be the first one
to to note that like i don't have a public hub
repo um you know i i could i choose mentorship and
coaching as um the way that i i contribute so i
have a lot of time for my own projects which is um
i don't know mixed feelings about but
um anyways uh you know i think that um
i think that it can be very effective though in
terms of like showing what you can do early on um
and and and getting yourself from the
analysts to the data science position um
you know there's one like kind of odd
habit that i have um at least i think
it's odd maybe other people won't but
i have a permanent job search alert um
in google jobs um you know my what
i'm interested in is experimentation
but um you know you might be interested
in in finance or something different um
and so you know a couple keywords and i just
have it come to my inbox you know weekly or some
cadence the reason why i do that is because um it
helps me stay fresh with what's going on around me
uh particularly if i'm not in conferences or
you know if i'm not able to connect with um
data scientists outside my company it just
keeps helps me keep a finger on the pulse
of what's going on in the industry in
terms of skills people are looking for
the way that data science is kind of starting
to form into different subspecialties um and
the reason why i'm recommending that is because of
that skills-based focus when you start looking at
a lot of job descriptions you start to pick up on
those patterns and so you'll start to pick up on
what kind of a data scientist you want to be based
on what you like to do but you also need a better
sense of what kind of skills they're looking
for and where you really need to focus in on
i don't know if that's helpful no i
appreciate that it's always good to hear
different points of view because
you're going to miss something like
i was reading a lot from the chat i was like
a lot of people had great suggestions too so
it's good thanks everyone jenny i see you
have your hand raised you want to jump in
um sure thanks um this is about resume review
kind of you know mentoring slash resume review so
yesterday uh you know we do we have a couple of
open open positions at our company in data science
and analytics which i will i will share but um
i got forwarded a resume by a friend of a friend
saying is this person qualified for one of the
roles i'm seeing and so i i looked over the resume
and noticed immediately you know she had listed
the bullet points under each of her job titles
she was listing them in a sending order of
importance or impressiveness so the things
that were most impressive she was putting last and
she was also in some of her bullet points she was
sort of being really deferential to her colleagues
like you know i've been working under my mentor to
do this or and then i looked at her linkedin page
and saw there were a bunch of accomplishments and
job responsibilities that were really
impressive that were listed on her linkedin page
and that hadn't made it onto her resume so my
answer was you know i'm not sure whether or not
she's qualified for this job but forget about that
she really needs to overhaul her resume it's not
showing how great she is and i gave you know
specific advice which apparently she really
appreciated but you know it really hit me um
what's the like what's a mechanism for this i mean
it just so happened that someone forwarded me the
resume and i was nice enough to take 10 minutes to
do this but not everyone is going to do that and
is there does anyone know of like a forum does
our studio have a forum for this
does our ladies have a forum for this
um because especially for people who are very
uncomfortable with self-promotion um it just the
resume just reeked of that and i felt horrible
um yeah she was just really you know really uh
shooting herself in the foot and i'm sure
it's really common i'm not going to lie i
was there myself when i first um when i first
started looking for a job before grad school
um yeah i just i didn't i just didn't get it you
know like i it's it's it's funny to me now i will
share with people my very first resume that i was
using and and i show them like where i started i
show them kind of somewhere in the middle where i
was looking for an internship and then i show them
where i am now you know and how it's evolved over
time um but you know like my thought process when
i first graduated was like well i have a degree
in physics what else do you want to know i i can i
can i could do anything right you know it was just
so youthfully arrogant but um but you know like
you gotta like i i take the time
because i'm a sucker and i don't say no
and you know i'll i'll help people like you
need to make it easy for people to connect the
dots because that was not obvious to me before i
thought everybody could just connect the dots um
and they were in my head or something like that
but like what what it is to me is indicative of
someone who you know probably doesn't
have a lot of confidence and it's probably
not in a good um when i see a resume like
that and then the the the difference like
that probably tells me they're just not in good
culture they probably have never experienced
good work culture um and i absolutely want to have
a conversation with them and learn more about them
see how they sell themselves um but in terms of
like approaching the wider problem i i really love
um maybe our lady supporting resume reviews as
part of some of the chapters if that's something
they're interested in um you can always tweet at
them ideas i'm sure they're open to it i'm not
organizing right now um otherwise i take it there
um there are a lot of preparation um companies
coming up but you know at the end of the day
it comes down to people who can afford them
um which doesn't feel great um so
you know i think that maybe just
we all take a vow to lead by example and um you
know make a call to action on our own networks
like are you are you actively mentoring because
you should be you know it's our responsibility to
bring up the data scientists of the future and
so um we all gotta chip in on that when we can
yeah i i did post about this on the our ladies
new york city chapter slack um you know haven't
heard anything back but i'm guessing the answer is
that's a great idea jenny why don't you organize
that like i know i know that's the answer you
know yeah yeah i think that's something that
we could probably look to look into too as
part of the data science hangout website or
we'll we'll chat more about that internally and
jenny maybe i can reach out to you to ask for
some more information too um i'll also put that
into the linkedin group too and we can continue
the discussion about that there as well but along
with our ladies maybe also the r for data science
online learning community slack would be a good
place to do that too sour is going by super fast
um i just want to make sure there aren't questions
that i've missed because i see justin you had put
one into the chat with a star for me to read so
the question was as someone new to this discipline
can you speak about the intersection of social
science and data science i'm especially interested
in understanding which analysis might
be most useful to learn as my company's
survey guy slash milton from office space
that's funny um surveys are great to know
because i think you know um when you're talking
about the intersection of social science
and data science um you start working with
uh ux researchers so the user experience
um and there are a lot of companies that actually
um really double down on mixed methods research so
you have a data scientist working with a product
manager a designer and a software development team
and they're a little squad and they they chip
away at their corner of the universe um for
example i know spotify is is one such organization
um and anybody who is looking to learn more about
uh mixed methods research um centerstat.org
is um is a small um statistical group
that does stats workshops and the quality is
amazing um so i know they have a course available
um highly recommended i haven't taken it yet but
i plan on it um network analysis is another one
um i don't think it's used much right it's not
commonly used but i can see more and more usage
for network analysis in data science um it's one
of those things where and you'll see this in some
of the courses because they also have a network
analysis course on center stat um i'm affiliated
with them in no way i just really do love their
classes um but uh yeah it's it's kind of the
statistics question of uh how do you how do you
want to model your data do you want to understand
it and network science network analysis is is
really an a powerful dimension in that regard um
but i think there's there's also just like a lot
of value in having data scientists who understand
or even just thoughtful about the people
part of things all right that makes sense
i appreciate it thank you you're welcome thanks
justin thanks christy i am i'm scrolling through
to see questions from earlier but just want to say
if anybody is still on and had a question that i
didn't see please feel free to unmute yourself
or raise your hand here and and jump in too
hi yeah i have a quick
question sorry i'm i'm outside
um i only logged in about half an hour ago now i'm
great to listen one of the things i've been trying
to figure out is how to benchmark your skill sets
um so i've just finished a phd in neuroscience
dealt with lumber you know a lot you
know very classical kind of phd to data
science but i just struggle with kind of
figuring out how competent i am or i'm not
you know i don't know if you have any
could speak to that a little bit thank you
you're welcome that's a good question
i don't i don't know what this says about
me but i've never asked myself that question
um i don't know i mean um
like i think that maybe i can just like you
know like like sorry um yeah without say just
like you know without just listing like do you
know these packages have you applied you know
have you applied these kind
of methods to these cut like
that is one way i think to kind of do it i was
just wondering if there is a better way to kind of
figure out where you lie in the hierarchy
of competence in a sense without that being
a negative way just in ways like a my six
months of training away or actually am i
like a mid-level data scientist but just don't
know the right labels outside of my niche yeah
yeah you know again like i i
kind of um i don't want to say
that you're wrong um so i don't want to say that
this is like a wrong way to think about things but
i i kind of want to encourage you to think about
it a little differently um in the sense that um
like if if if you're always
measuring in absolutes where you are
um you're you're just gonna be chasing a
a moving target forever that goal post is
is going to keep moving there's going to be
more and more and more and more um i mean even
just from the perspective of the technology
front um when i started we were in hadoop and
i still have to like learn the aws ecosystem
now and by the time i learn that there will
probably be something else and we're all going
to have to rebuild our data infrastructure again
um if anybody's panicking don't i'm being
exaggerating but yeah so but my point is is that
um i i like to measure myself a little bit
more relatively you know um so when i when i
read technical blogs i'm not necessarily thinking
about my skill set and like you know if i'm solid
enough in the tidy verse what i'm thinking about
is what problems does my business need to solve
do we have the skill set to solve those um
and um you know where are we relative to other
comparable companies are they are they solving
the same problems are they light years ahead of
us or like are are we all kind of like figuring
things out in the dark and making the same like
similar decisions and and i've found it's been
the latter for the most part along my journey
like going to conferences and and talking to
people who work in my space i find we all kind
of have the same struggles and so to me that tells
me that as a team we're doing all right um and
that is what matters to me a little bit more um
but i i also have just kind of this like ominous
confidence or faith i i'm not a faith-driven
person in any way i'm like show me show me proof
but like i do have this faith in that um you know
if i'm doing i'm doing the things that i like um
if i'm solving problems um that are
actually impactful then i'm doing my job
and it doesn't really matter how many packages i
know that's yeah that's a sorry that is a that's a
really nice answer so um that does help it's just
you know i think it's finding the balance between
overconfidence and yeah like okay i don't know
that but i could give me a week and i can do that
versus being naive um i think there's something
that we can all just do as data scientists
and i i think it's like we just need to like we
need to stop this toxic like what do you know
attitude like because that's not what it's about
you know one of one of the data scientists that i
interviewed for for my new role she is one of the
most well-respected data scientists in her company
um you know and she comes
from a statistics background
and um i see it repeatedly that inferential
statisticians get judged differently than
than machine learning data scientists and it
creates all of this like this conflict and
in this like i said toxicity and
it's it's it's not a contest um
you know we all have complementary
skills we can all learn from each other
um so let's just do that instead of
complaining about it or you know saying
pitting people against each other suggesting
one type of data scientist is less than another
thank you great answer thank you kirsty i
know where something really jump in yeah
i just think uh when interviewing whether for data
science or any roles like willingness to learn and
actually meaning it like is the biggest thing
above the skills you already know or the skills
you will know it's just that like you're eager
and you want to be growing into part of the team
um that was i don't know
that's something that i always
try to get across when i'm interviewing
because i know i don't know everything
at all and i would like to i don't know grow
in the position that when you're rooting for
that's a great point kate agreed
i know we are a little bit over here so i want
to see if you had a few more minutes christy
what do you have to read i don't have a job right
now so you're like yeah let's talk all day um
i see there was a question anonymous
question i had missed earlier that was
how do you think industry
plays a role in data science
higher for example moving from retail
to tech or non-profit to fintech
um i mean this is i don't know like i i would
be curious how other hiring managers think
about this because this is something that i've
i've definitely um struggled up against myself
uh before i realized that you know uh
experimentation is going to be my my path um
moving forward um i i did apply for some
growth roles and um thought it'd be interesting
because i really like i said i wanted
to connect to that people piece
but the feedback that i got was they needed
someone with growth experience um and
i took that again as well they need someone
who can hit the ground running and that was
exactly the feedback that i got so once
they have that first key like senior hire
they can hire people that maybe have transferable
skills um so you know when you're when you're
when you're doing that pivot just just keep
that in mind is that you know the team does
have a specific composition of experience
they're looking for um and so um
you know you you might have to work harder
for it but you can get it um does anyone
else though uh have anything to contribute
about sort of cross-domain data science hiring
i think uh you made a great point that
doesn't really get talked about enough
is that especially when you're coming from
recruiting you don't know how like one of
the big questions that i ask at every interview is
what's the team structure you don't know if you're
the first person uh they're starting bradley
team or second or however big the team is
so i think that's something that
needs to be taken to account as
even if you're willing to show that you're you
want to learn for me anyway i want to make sure
there's something else that i can actually
learn from i don't want to be just learning
by myself i want to have something that's been
there done that so that's a big part for me
that i think that you briefly touched
upon but i wanted to touch upon more
excellent point so i think from my experience
the more traditional the industry i won't say the
easier the interview is but the less theoretical
it's going to be like if you're if you and i've
interviewed with fintechs and everything else and
they want to get into this theoretical game or
they think you're some software engineer that's
going to develop the new recursive algorithm to
solve the traveling salesman problem and that's
what that's what you can have focused on um
interviewing banking insurance health care all
these others it's basic problem solving yeah you
go through a handful of those stats questions you
know can you figure out the average of you know
some money and or whatever and you know how
would you segment customers going to a sports
game i mean some stuff like that like those
are the how do you think generic questions but
um they have and and and same thing i mean
i've been a leader i've seen hundreds of
resumes and done quite a handful of interviews
and um none of that stuff matters to me
like and and i've seen it in a couple linkedin
posts like and and the end of the day is if it's
on your resume you're going you should be prepared
to be asked about it rule if i'm number one um
really thought you know rule of thumb your
resume i mean this is i'm old school so i
transitioned from the military now we used
to always say your resume should be the 3m
principle men money and machinery how much
did you manage and what did you do with it
job just laundry list of job descriptions
aren't going to get you anywhere
uh into someone's point on here putting your
least significant thing at the bottom disaster
um and in fact i'm reviewing somebody some random
person's resume one of my discord course channels
uh and they put all their courses up on page one
and a page two is all their work experience and
they said to me we're trying to transition jobs
i'm like no one's going to get you you're not
going to get an offer you're not going to talk to
anybody and here's why and and so it's you know
some things like that um but uh and and i always
tell a lot of people don't look for the entry
level data science job you know it is literally
the one in a million go for um that marketing or
that finance or that ops job somewhere basic where
you're going to show up maybe they want you to run
xl all day but you know what you can go and run
r all day um and and change the game um and i've
done that a couple places and now you have bullets
on your resume you don't have to be there forever
the job you're taking isn't the rest of your life
the job you're taking is i don't know two years
for years um could be less i mean i've spent
one year in many jobs um and it goes fast yeah
there's no benchmark like i you know one of the
things like i don't believe i don't believe in a
posture syndrome i know people feel it i don't
believe in it because you know what there is
always somebody that knows way more than you do
down the road so so stop thinking about that is
do you have the skills and the requisite
experience to the job you're being asked
that's the question um and that's what you got to
answer and so you know you didn't get asked to put
a shuttle on the moon you got asked to solve some
basic business problems and you know that's it and
you know think of yourself are you can
you do that are you solving those problems
and does it do you have experience to
do it or can you reach a little bit
um i mean i've never been fully prepared for every
every job i ever took because i you know it's
one of those you have some basic set of skills
then you get there you're like oh boy this is
a bit more so you grow a little bit like every
new job should be a stretch and if it's not
you know maybe looking for the easy one i
don't know um but every new job's that way
um and i'm gonna record this as a pep
talk anytime i feel impostor syndrome
we are not impossible we just don't know know
everything um and that's okay it really is
um definitely sloan i i know you had a question
earlier and i can't find it in the chat because
there's so many awesome comments too if you
want to jump in sure um christy everything
that you were saying about the people aspect of
data science is speaking to me a lot that's what
i love the most about data science and i also
have most of my background in data science is
also experimentation um but i'm fairly new into
my career and i already know that the people
aspect is where i find the most value and i i'm
starting to do a little bit of mentorship but i
i'd love to hear more about your path and how you
were able to mentor more people and maybe some
advice that you would give someone that knows that
that's the path that they want to go down as well
yeah um
you know i mean it i gotta say like my my
journey has been um oh i don't want to say
you know i don't want to say just luck because
there's a lot of hard work that went into it um
but there's also a lot of luck you know um i i got
lucky um while i was in grad school i won't tell
you my full full full journey because that would
take way too long um we'll just say i went to
i think 13 no nine colleges and universities
over the course of 13 years and five majors
um so yeah it's complicated but um but
like when i think about my journey i i got lucky
with um starting at groupon um because working
there as an intern or a contract analyst is what
it was while i was in grad school um allowed me
to get in there and and make some relationships
and so when i did graduate from grad school i
was lucky enough to um to already have established
contacts there so going back to i don't remember
whose point it was but the idea that you know
those opportunities can come from from anywhere um
i being creative about where you look for
opportunities that internship was a tableau gig
i was a tableau administrator it was miserable i
didn't like doing it i didn't do it for very long
but it was the key that got me into my next job at
groupon and i had actually worked with my hiring
manager briefly and i tell this story to him he
knows it briefly before i left and i remember i
saw the job and it was his job opening and i was
like oh gosh chris he's kind of weird is what my
first impression of my my future boss and mentor
was but i decided to do a google search on him
and um turns out that he is someone who really
cares about building teams and uh trust and
communication and all those core tenants of what
makes great teams great um and that was that's the
thing that he is committed to and so i had a great
mentor right off the bat um he fun fact he had
say a two and a two hour commute home like to and
from the office every day he took the metra in and
out and so on the metra here in chicago he taught
himself r so that he could be a better coach for
me knowing that i was a new grad in my role um and
like so that's the kind of boss you want to find
and that's how i got lucky but part of it was
intentional i googled him and he had an online
presence and i knew that that was his brand and
that was what he was about um and i got a lot of
growth there i mean he used to joke half-heartedly
that you know he only knows three things it's
probably like 10 things neither of us have written
them down but those core tenants that he taught me
um you know about community about uh about
growth about resolving conflict about um about
you know learning and friction and building trust
those are all things that i learned from him um
so again like i said just build
relationships and the rest is gravy
definitely thanks chrissy i like zach's comment
then that's not luck then it's research fair
good job well if you would have heard my tech
screen you you'd agree with me that it was luck
i see that people were um commenting about
different titles for data science jobs and
libby said yeah call me what you wanted to call me
but i had a question someone had reached out to me
from a large insurance company and they have this
role data science engineer that people just they
just haven't been finding candidates for and we
were wondering if it could also be like that title
doesn't come up as much for people in their
job search yeah um it's a lot of creativity
and titles right now i thought like we had kind of
landed into settled settled territory but there's
um what we got we've got data science engineer
is a new one to me i haven't heard that one
um i think another one that's kind of
controversial right now is decision science
what's the difference between a decision scientist
and a data scientist um my last title was decision
scientist and i still can't tell you my guess
is that you tend to see decision science and
logistics a little bit more they tend
to deal with metric soup more often um
but yeah i mean i personally i don't think
titles are important again like i'm focused
on what i'm doing and so um if i'm doing what
i want to be doing and i'm paid a a fairly um
then that's that's what i'm mostly
concerned about and that i'm growing
that i'm pointed in the direction that i want to
be and then i'm making progress um but you know
i guess i would ask myself how is a data
science engineer different from a data scientist
um and what kind of a candidate are you
trying to attract uh yeah i think it
maybe could be a mismatch of the title because i
wonder if i think the role is actually for like
um administrating data science tools for them
i'm not sure i see yeah yeah that's a tough one
i mean i think that person would probably
be a little bit more if they're implementing
data science tools or administrating and
implementing um i've seen them usually as
an analyst or a developer physician i think
engineer i think data science and engineer
it's like almost putting two really
like um not well-defined terms together
making it even less well-defined
yeah maybe nobody's nobody's sure to
apply for it yeah i'm like i'm not what
it does and i'm not sure what an engineer
does no but um yeah i think there's an
opportunity to be a little bit more
creative and targeted in there yeah
definitely um okay i'm scrolling through the chat
to see if there are any other questions i missed
just want to put it out there to everyone to
raise your hand if i missed you i'm sorry if i did
i love this conversation today
christy thank you so much
thank you for having me it's one
of my favorite things to talk about
this is great okay i'll give people a few
more seconds to jump in with last questions
um but chrissy what's the best way for people to
follow up with you if they have other questions
is it linkedin or twitter what do
you prefer pretty active on linkedin
um one of my goals this year is to figure out
how to use twitter i've had a few false starts
we can i'll share your linkedin through the
data science hangout group but also just want
to remind people that we have that so if there are
certain conversations that you want to continue
there's the data science hangout community
group on linkedin let me put that in the
chat here again here we go you all so much for
watching do you have one thing if that's okay
and it it's having something in your background
for a zoom interview uh i've got football show
back there and interview you can talk about
five ten minutes talks about uh like getting you
they'll ask you about it get you talking about and
it helps you like sort of calm down so because of
course you're it's your you're at home for zoom
interviews you can sort of help dictate what's
in the background so that's something that i found
quite useful that is magical access a professional
i can talk about plants
aaron i see you had your hand raised too
uh yeah earlier uh when we're talking about
linkedin um one thing i struggle with is what
to put on linkedin versus what to put on your
resume um mine's kind of a jumbled mess um so do
you have any kind of guidelines on on how much
you should put on linkedin versus your resume
yeah um i mean i think it probably depends on the
depth and breadth of your background and what you
want to highlight um for example i'm i'm not a phd
i don't have a lot of research or publications to
share so um for me what i showcase is going to be
a little bit different than what um someone who
comes from a research background might showcase
um but i would say i my linkedin profile um
is almost a carbon copy of my resume just not
as updated um maybe a little bit more brief
no it's the same i think i don't pay
much attention to it as you can tell
it's got it has the essential information um and
and and then a couple of um maybe articles that i
was featured in where i talked about the work that
i was doing um enough context so that somebody
understands what it is that i do um and and what i
have to offer um for me i just i view my linkedin
um as a way for me to connect with people that
i'm interested in connecting with but also like
as far as i'm concerned like it's also just the
minimum information that a recruiter needs to
like determine whether or not i'm
someone they want to connect with
like that's i see that i see some some people
literally just have a title and that's it no
description and some people go into like a book
for each position so i just wanted if you had a
preference i think that i mean because i have
and this isn't a humble brag it's just i have
a ton of recruiters reach out to me all of the
time and um i think that that is uh an artifact
largely of my network that i've developed um
people that i'm connected to the people that i
maintain relationships and my activity on linkedin
um i think that those things all drive i mean
my it's not like my first job was at facebook my
first stop was at groupon you know i mean there
was a moment there where they almost got de-listed
it's it's not i mean they have a good reputation
for um for developing good technical people um but
it's it's not a it's not a huge successful name um
so yeah i i put my effort into my my personal
relationships and my professional relationships
thank you you're welcome i do think it's helpful
when people like introduce themselves through
linkedin too and like the little bio that's there
but it's nice that like you can include i don't
know your favorite posts that will be featured
at the top so everybody sees those too yeah yeah
that's good advice i didn't know you could do
that i think i spend too much time on linkedin
um but yeah but also connecting with people that
are in like the area that you want to get into
too because i think that if once you like like
their posts or comment on them other people will
see you in that area too they'll reach out and
connect with you and while we're on the topic of
linkedin um one other thing that i think is really
helpful is if someone does connect with you and
to always say like thank you for connecting and
just open the door to conversation with them
because you don't know why they were coming
to your profile and maybe they don't want to
just like reach out and ask you a question right
away but at least saying something to them kind
of opens the door to that awesome well thank
you so much christy for joining us and sharing
all your insights and thank you all for all the
questions too thank you so much for having me
you